en esta imagen de aquí tomamos el
cuadrado y dividimos en 100 partes
iguales y hemos coloreado vamos a ver
cuántos colorea moss cada uno de estos
renglones tiene 10 cuadritos así que
tenemos 10 20 30 40 41 42 43 44 45 46 47
aquí tenemos coloreados o iluminados 47
de 100 cuadros o también pueden decir
que esto que está iluminado en azul y
verde representa 47 centésimos de todo
me entero ahora lo que quiero hacer es
descomponer esta fracción de manera que
tenga yo 4 sobre 10 más algo que esté
sobre 100 y voy a escribirlo como una
estrella estrella entre 100 mi pregunta
es que va a ser igual a esta estrella y
los invito a qué pausa en el vídeo para
que traten de resolver esto por su
cuenta
bueno vamos a resolver estos juntos
una cosa que podemos decir
inmediatamente es que 47 sobre 100 es
igual a 40 sobre 100 lo vemos aquí 10 20
30 40 40 centésimos
aquí tenemos 10 aquí tenemos 20 aquí van
30 y aquí 40 más 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
centésimos + 7 sobre 100 ahora 40 sobre
es lo mismo que 4 sobre 10 40 centésimas
es lo mismo que cuatro décimas y hay
muchas formas que podemos ver esto una
de ellas es dividir este cuadro más
grande en décimas
esta es una décima
esta es otra décima dos décimas
estas son tres décimas y lo único que
estoy haciendo aquí es dividir el entero
este cuadro grande en décimas en lugar
de dividirla en centésimas le estoy
dividiendo en décimas
cuatro décimas
cinco décimas
seis décimas
siete décimas
ocho décimas
nueve décimas y finalmente diez décimas
fíjense que si vemos las líneas naranja
tengo / me entero no en centésimas o en
cien partes iguales sino en diez partes
iguales en décimas así que vemos estas
cuarenta centésimas que están en azul es
lo mismo que tener una décima dos
décimas
tres décimas
y cuatro décimas aquí van mis cuatro
décimas otra forma de pensar en esto es
cuando pasamos de centésimas a décimas
cada diez centésimas van a ser iguales a
una décima
así que dividimos tanto el denominador
entre 10 como el numerador así pasamos
de centésimas a décimas y lo mismo
hacemos con el numerador dividimos el
numerador entre 10 y así pasamos de
centésimas a décimas 40 dividido entre
10 es 4 siguen dividido entre 10 es 10 y
con eso yo espero que ustedes estén
convencidos de que 40 centésimos es
igual a 4 décimos pero que es lo que nos
queda pues aquí seguimos teniendo estas
7 centésimas aquí así que 40 centésimas
más 7 centésimas es lo mismo que cuatro
décimas más siete centésimas
así que esta estrella de acá que voy a
quitar la voy a borrar puedo escribirla
como siete centésimas así que 47
centésimas que es todo lo que tengo
iluminado acá va a ser igual a cuatro
décimas que es lo mismo que 40
centésimas lo que tengo resaltado en
azul más estas 12 345 67 centésimas 47
centésimas es igual a cuatro décimas más
siete centésimas